Pig
b
h
hi
[Music]
subscribe wow this place is
amazing wait something is
here spooky spooky jungle animals spooky
spooky I'm scared so scared
[Music]
We're Alone In The Deep Jungle I'm
scared I'm scared I'm
scared run run to the lake splish splash
splash let's ride on the raft smack
smack smack it's a crocodile spooky
spooky jungle animals spooky spooky I'm
scared so scared
We're Alone In The Deep Jungle I'm
scared I'm scared I'm
scared clim clim up the tree 1 2
3 no one will find us
here hi it's a snake spooky spooky
jungle animals spooky spooky I'm scared
so
scared we're are alone in the Deep
Jungle I'm scared I'm scared I'm
scared hide hide in the bush swish swish
swish we are safe now CHP
chump it's a venous fly trap spooky
spooky jungle animals spooky spooky I'm
scared so
scared we're alone in the Deep Jungle
I'm scared I'm scared I'm
scared head head to the cave rush rush
rush let's get some rest stop stop
stop it's a gorilla we're not that scary
we'll help you find your way back home
I kind and friendly jungle animals and
friendly we're here to help kind and
friendly jungle animals kind and
friendly we all
[Music]
friends the wheels on the bus go round
and round round and round round and
round the wheel s on the bus go round
and round all through the
f a pig on the bus goes oink oink oink
oink oink oink oink oink oink the pig on
the bus goes oink oink oink all through
the
[Music]
farm the donkey on the bus goes heha hea
heaw the donkey on the BS goes heaw all
to the
F the duck on the bus goes quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack the duck on the bus goes quack
quack quack all through the
[Music]
farm the cow on the bus goes moo moo moo
moo moo moo moo moo moo the cow on the
bus goes moo moo moo all through the
farm
[Music]
the farm animals go up and down up and
down up and down the farm animals go up
and down all through the
[Music]
farm the wheels on the bus go round and
round round and round round and round
the wheels on the bus go round and round
all through the farm
the pig on the bus goes oink oink oink
oink oink oink oink oink oink the pig on
the bus goes oink oink oink all through
the
[Music]
farm the donkey on the bus goes he he he
the donkey on the bus goes hea all
through the
[Music]
farm the dck the bus goes quack quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack the duck on the bus goes quack
quack quack all through the
[Music]
farm the cow on the bus goes moo moo moo
moo moo moo moo moo moo the cow on the
bus goes moo moo moo all through the
farm the farm animals go up and down up
and down up and down the farm animals go
up and down all through the farm
[Music]
baby monkey Banas baby monkey Banas baby
monkey Banas bananas mommy monkey Bas
mommy monkey Bas mommy monkey Bas
bananas daddy monkey Bas daddy monkey
Banas daddy monkey Bas bananas Grandma
monkey Banas Grandma monkey Banas
grandpa monkey ban B grandpa monkey ban
grandpa monkey ban Grand Mony b
[Music]
bananas
ban Yum Yum yuman Yum Yum Yum ban Yum
Yum Yum ban n ban it's
the it's the it's
the
bananas keep going
[Music]
baby monkey Banas baby monkey Banas baby
monkey Bas bananas mommy monkey Banas
mommy monkey Bas mommy monkey Bas
bananas daddy monkey Bas daddy monkey
Bas daddy monkey Bas bananas Grandma
monkey B Grandma monkey Bas Grandma
monkey Bas Banas Grandma monkey
monke
[Music]
bananas yum yum
Yan
ban Banas one more time
[Music]
baby monkey ban baby monkey ban baby
monkey Banas bananas mommy monkey mmy
monkey mmy monkey bananas daddy monkey
daddy monkey daddy monkey bananas
Grandma monkey B Grand monkey B Grand
monkey Banas Grand monkey grand monke
grand monkey B
[Music]
more
B yum yum yum
[Music]
ban
ban hello farm animals 1 2 3 4
5 big finger Big Finger where are you
here I am here I am how do you do pig
finger Pig finger where are you here I
am here I am how do you do wiggle wiggle
the finger
family o o
[Music]
o dog finger dog finger where are you
here I am here I am how do you do dog
finger dog finger where are you here I
am here I am
how do you do wiggle wiggle the finger
family la la la la la quack quack
quack cow finger cow finger where are
you here I am here I am how do you do
Cal finger cow finger where are you here
I am here I am how do you do wiggle
wiggle the finger
family moo
[Music]
moo she finger she finger where are you
here I am here I am how do you do sh
finger she finger where are you here I
am here I am how do you do Wile wiggle
the finger
family chicken finger chicken finger
where are you here I am here I am how do
you do chicken finger chicken finger
you do Wile Wile finger
[Music]
family happy animal fingers la la la la
la happy F animal fingers la la la la la
happy F animal fingers la la la la la
happy F animal fingers la la la la
[Music]
la friends I brought sleeping bags for
us
take one e ooh look here my sleeping bag
has a map on it oh no Peppe that's not a
map drawing it's pee I think someone
peed on your sleeping bag what no way
why would someone pee on my sleeping bag
I'm going to find who did
it who is it who is it who is the CIT
pea
it'sa
it'sa I'm sure it is
Peppa Peppa is the one who did this to
the bag who me yes you it's not me then
who did
it maybe
Pepe who is it who is it who is the CIT
pee it's pee it's
pee I'm sure
bir Let's Go Peppa is the one who did
this to the bag who me yes you it's not
me and who did it h let me think about
it but wait wait how can I be the one
who peed on it this is my sleeping
bag it should be someone else who is
near us in the
forest pink Fong
huh who is it who is it who is the C Bri
pink Fong it's pink F it's
pink I'm sure it is pong yes pong is the
one who did this to the B me yes you
it's not me who did it maybe pepp
[Music]
huh who is it who is it
who is the CIT pepp it's pepp it's
pepp I'm sure who is PE Let's Go PE is
the one who did this to the bag who me
yes you it's not me who did it I have no
idea now oh
[Music]
no who is it who is it who is the car
culprit who let's find out let's find
out who is the culprit oh my please tell
me who did
[Music]
it knock knock knock Yellow Barn knock
knock knock who's inside peekaboo
peekaboo
[Music]
knock knock knock Yellow Barn knock
knock knock who's inside hello hello I'm
a yellow duck in a Yellow
[Music]
Barn knock knock knock pink Barn knock
knock knock who's inside peekaboo
peekaboo
[Music]
knock knock knock pink Barn knock knock
knock who's inside hello
hello I'm a pink pig in a pink
[Music]
Barn knock knock knock orange Barn knock
knock knock who's inside peekaboo
[Music]
peekaboo knock knock knock orange one
knock knock knock who's inside hello
hello I'm an orange cat in an orange
[Music]
Barn knock knock knock Green Barn knock
knock knock who's inside peekaboo
[Music]
peekaboo knock knock knock greenn knock
knock knock who's inside hello hello I'm
a green frog in a green
[Music]
barn knock knock knocks White Barn knock
knock knocks who's inside peeka boar
peka knock knock knock White knock knock
knock who's inside hello hello I'm a
white sheep been a wi
[Music]
Barn knock knock knock Brown Barn knock
knock knock who's inside peekaboo
peekaboo knock knock knock Brown Barn
knock knock knock who's inside hello
hello I'm a brown horse in a brown Barn
[Music]
elephant H elepant
H elephant Flamingo H Flamingo H
Flamingo flamingo
buffalo
buffalo the
buffalo thep
buffalo
Ze
zebra
Zeb giraff h giraff h giraff h
[Music]
Gira lion
roaring
roar
[Music]
sa
sa sa
[Music]
had a little rooster by the barard gate
that little rooster was my
playmate that little rooster
when do do
do had a little rooster couldn't fly
that rooster went off byebye that little
rooster went run run run Co
[Music]
do had a little rooster who had two
wings that little rooster flat as he
spins that little rooster went flap flap
flap run run run
[Music]
had a little rooster who had five chicks
that little rooster played high and SE
peekaboo that little rooster
went flap flap flap run run
run do do do
do had a little rooster who like to eat
that little rooster ate worms and Wheats
that little rooster went Yum Yum
[Music]
Yum flap flap flap run run run
had a little rooster who love to sing
that little rooster s all through spring
that little rooster went la la Yum Yum
Yum Boo Boo
Boo run run
[Music]
run do
my Sailors are you all ready yes Captain
we are ready to go okay huh what's going
on here the boat is not moving at all
hello actually I'm really afraid of
water oh no my friends we need to do
something to get our boat ceiling in the
sea okay let's go let's
go there was a scared tiny little boat
there was a scared tiny little boat
there was a scared tiny little boat it
couldn't sail couldn't sail couldn't
Sail on the sea 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 Days
passed 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 days pass 1 2 3 4 5
6 seven days pass it couldn't sail
couldn't sail couldn't sa on the sea
what should we do to help the little
boat to S what should we do to help the
little bo to sale what should we do to
help the little bo to S let's keep
trying keep trying keep trying and
trying there was a scared tiny little
boat there was a scared tiny little boat
there was a scared tiny little boat they
couldn't sail couldn't sail couldn't
Sail on the sea 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 B pass 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 weeks pass 1 2 3 4 5 six seven
weeks pass it couldn't sail couldn't sa
couldn't Sail on Thea what should we do
to help the little boat to sell what
should we do to help the little boat to
sell what should we do to help the
little let's keep trying keep trying
keep trying and trying
let's keep trying keep trying keep
trying
try there was a scared tiny little boat
there was a scared tiny little boat they
was scared tiny little boat they
couldn't sail couldn't sail couldn't
Sail on the sea 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 months
pass 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 months 1 2 3 4 5 6
seven months P start sailing start
sailing start sailing and
[Music]
[Applause]
sailing Peppa we need to
hurry aw but I really don't want to get
ready Peppa okay okay what should I do
first to get ready then hey I know just
the right friend who can help you with
[Music]
that let me introduce my good friend
ping
Pon ping
pong ping Pon is a cute doll that's made
out of cardboard ping Pon can wash his
face with soap squish
Splash pink Pon brushes his hair with
his favorite hairbrush pin Pon never
cries even when his hair gets
stuck pin Pon shakes my hand like a
really good friend please be my best
friend pin Pon pin Pon P pong P pong P
pong P
[Music]
pong P pong P pong P pong P pong our
best friend la la la made out of
cardboard so cute so handsome la la la
la all right Pepe now you know what to
do of course p is a cute doll that's
made out of cardboard ping Pon can wash
his face with so Splish
Splash pimp Pon brushes his hair with
his favorite hairbrush pimp Pon never
cries even when his hair gets
stuck pone shakes my hand like a really
good friend please be my best friend P
Pon P Pon P Pon p p p p p
p pon pon pon pon our best friend la la
la made out of cardboard so cute so
handsome la la la
[Music]
la B Bon is a cute doll that's made out
of cardboard
Pon can wash his face with soap Splish
Splash ping pom brushes his teeth with
his favorite toothbrush pimp pom puts on
pajamas before he goes to
sleep pink pong heads to bed and lies
down to sleep and stars are shining
right up of ping Pon pin pong pin Pon
pin Pon ping pong
our best friend la la la made out of
cardboard so cute so handsome la la la
la oh sweet
dreams who are you who are you I can't
guess the animals on the farm
[Music]
Who Am I who am I pop pop I have a short
curly
tail I don't know who Could It
Be Who Am I who am I pop pop I have a
squishy round
nose ah you are a
pig yes yes I am an oink oink Pig
[Music]
Who Am I who am I pop pop I have two
little
wings I don't know who Could It
Be Who Am I who am I pop pop I have a
comb on my
head aha you are
a yes yes I am a
Roar Who Am I who am I pop pop I have a
bouncy fluffy
tail I don't know who Could It
Be Who Am I who am I pop pop I have to
pointy
ears aha you are a
bunny yes yes I am a
bunny Who Am I who am I pop pop I have a
long flat
beak I don't know who Could It
Be Who Am I who am I pop pop I have wide
wet feet aha you are a d
yes yes I am a quack quack
[Music]
dock Who Am I who am I pop pop I have a
large Popp
ears I don't know who Could It
Be Who Am I who am I pop pop I have a
big Wiggly tail aha you are a
Mouse yes yes I am a squeak squeak
[Music]
Mouse who are you who are you I can
guess the animals on the farm who are
you who are you I can't guess the
animals on the farm
KY up KY up KY up run around the farm
with me KY up KY up KY up I'm a rocket
hor up gy up up up up gy up gy up up gy
up gy upy up I a rocket
horse every time you look at me you'll
know just how fast I can be no one runs
as fast as me on this Farm 1un 2 3 run
run run around faster than the birds I
run run run run around faster than the
wind I
run K up ky ky up around the farm with
me gy up gy up G up I a rocket horse upy
up G up up gy up gy up up up
up I a rocket
horse every time I run around my long
round and goes up and down up and down
up and down anywhere the sun is found
round round round and round stomping on
the muddy CR round round round and round
I will never slow down ready get set up
K up K up K up K up K up K up K up
k i a
[Music]
rocket rocket
hor every time you look at me you'll
know just how fast I can be no one runs
as fast as me on this Farm 1 2 run run
run around faster than the birds I run
run around faster than the wind I
run KY up KY up kitty up run around the
farm with me KY up KY up KY
up I'm a rocket horse KY up KY up KY up
gy up gy up gy up gy up gy up gy up hey
I'm a rocket horse
[Music]
every time I run around my long brown
tail goes up and down up and down up and
down anywhere the sun is found round
round round and round stoping on the
muddy CR round round round and round I
will never slow down Ready Get Set KY up
KY up KY up KY up KY up KY up up up up
up upay I got a rocket horse up up up up
K up K up k k
k rocket
horse black and white black and white I
am Mrs Cow black and white black and
white black and white white I am Mrs Cow
black and
[Music]
white cow cow cow I am Mrs Cow when you
see me you will say wow wow cow cow cow
I am Mrs Cow I love everyone who loves a
cow milk milk milk fresh white milk I
feed my babies with my milk milk milk
milk milk milk fresh white milk I feed
my babies with my milk milk
[Music]
milk cow cow cow I am Mrs Cow when you
see me you will say wow W cow cow cow I
am Mrs Cow I love everyone who Lov the
cow cheese cheese cheese yummy yum
cheese my milk makes delicious cheese
cheese cheese cheese cheese cheese yumy
yum cheese my milk makes delicious
cheese cheese
cheese cow cow cow I am Mrs Cow when you
see me you will say wow wow cow cow cow
I am Mrs Cow I love everyone who loves
the
cow sing sing sing I sing sing sing I
like to sing the blues moo moo moo sing
sing sing I sing sing sing I like to
sing the blues moo moo mooo
woo
woooo cow cow cow I am Mrs Cow when you
see me you will say wowow cow cow cow I
am Mrs Cow I love everyone who loves a
cow
[Music]
welcome to the dance party everyone are
you all ready to dance the night
away put your hands up put your hands up
put your hands down put your hands down
you are all ready to dance now let's
[Music]
goes to sing and
dance loves to play all
day the happy
a who loves to dance dance it can shake
its hands up and down like
[Music]
this to sing and
dance loves to play all
day the tough
karacha who loves to dance
turning to the left turning to the
[Music]
right to sing and
dance to play all
day the
tall who loves to dance dance it can
shake its legs say right and left like
this sing and
dance loves to play all
day the cutest
karacha who loves to
dance if can shake it h to the side like
this
[Music]
to sing and
dance loves to play all
[Music]
day loves to sing and
dance loves to play all day one more
time loves to sing and dance
hoay loves to play all
day loves to sing and
dance loves to play all
day hey friends did you take good care
of my farm
animals yes ma'am did you feed my
cow yes ma'am could you tell me how yes
ma'am what did you feed her corn and hay
what did you feed her corn and hay did
you milk her good yes ma'am now did you
milk her like you should yes ma'am how
did you milk her squish squish squish
how did you milk her squish squish s
squish great nice job friends then what
about my oink oink
Pig did you feed my pig yes ma'am could
you tell me how yes SM what did you feed
him we and nuts what did you feed him we
and N did you scratch his back yes ma'am
now did you scratch him like you should
yes ma'am how did you scratch him side
to side how did you scratch him side to
side
awesome then what about my baaba
sheep did you feat my
sheep yes ma'am could you tell me how
yes ma'am what did you feed them Lett
and grass what did you feed them lettuce
and grass did you count them good yes
ma'am now did you count them like you
should yes ma'am how did you count them
1 2 3 how did you count them 1 2
3 perfect then what about my neigh neigh
horse did you Fe my my horse yes ma'am
could you tell me how yes ma'am what did
you feed her apples and carrots what did
you feed her apples and carrots did you
comb her man yes ma'am now did you comb
her like you should yes ma'am how did
you comb her up and down how did you
comb her up and down good job thank you
[Music]
friends 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 I can count
from 1 to 10 let's count numbers on the
farm I see one one cow I see one one cow
I see one one cow
no one cow on the farm I see two two
horses I see two two horses I see two
two
horses two horses on the f I see three
three sheep I see three three sheep I
see three three sheep
three sheep on the farm I see four four
pigs I see four four pigs I see four
four
pigs four pigs on the farm I see five
five dogs I see five five dogs I see
five five dogs woof woof woof woof woof
five dogs on the far 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 I can count from 1 to 10 let's count
numbers on the
farm I see six six cats I see six six
cats I see six six cats meow meow meow
meow meow meow six cats on the farm I
see seven seven chickens I see seven s
seven chickens I see seven seven
chickens seven chickens on the FL I see
eights eight Ducks I see eights eight
Ducks I see eights eight ducks quack
quack quack quack quack quack quack
quack eight ducks on the Flo I see N
Night CH I see nine nine chicks I see n
nine chicks ch ch ch
sheep sheep sheep sheep sheep
sheep nine chicks on the farm I see 10
10 I see 10 10 I see 10 10 sque sque
sque Sak sque squeak squeak squeak sque
sque 10 on
the 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 I can count
from 1 to 10 let's count numbers on the
[Music]
farm let's find the jumbled jungle
animal
sounds hi friends are you ready to
explore the jungle what animals do you
think live in the
[Music]
Jung friends did you hear that too
oh dear you were able to hear my quiet
movement I'm the jungle number one
villain snake I'm here to gobble the
jungle
animals everyone who loses their voice
under my spell will
[Music]
wither quack quack
oh no the animal sounds are all
jumbled friends I need your help to find
the animals
voices really you'll help me thank
you if you don't find your voice you'll
lose your strength and then I'm going to
eat you up in one bite
H woof
woof let's find the voice of the first
jungle animal
[Music]
crocodile oink
oink is it this one
[Applause]
oh no that must be
[Music]
wrong that's it this is the sound of a
fluffy
[Music]
sheep oh this is hard is it this
one oink oink
[Music]
one more mistake and I can eat the
crocodile
no oink oink yeah this is a px
sound should I swallow the tail or the
head
first the snake is getting closer hurry
let's find the
answer a
this is
[Music]
it it's the
answer can you tell me who lives in the
jungle grow grow it's a
crocodile a grow here a grow there here
a grow there a grow everywhere
a crocodile lives in the Green
[Applause]
Jungle his you ruined my meal you won't
be able to disturb me this
time quack
quack let's find the parrot's voice
hello ribbit
ribbit H is it this
one ribbit
[Music]
ribbit oh no friends this isn't the
answer ribbit
ribbit it's the sound of a jumping
frog H then is it this
one soon you'll be my delicious
[Music]
meal I got it
wrong it was the sound of a very fast
horse
should I make a fancy hat with a
parrot's
feathers parrot be careful the snake is
near let's see here it's this one
H I found it hello
[Music]
can you tell me who lives in the
jungle hello hello it's a
par with a Hello here and a hello there
here a hello there a hello everywhere
hello a par lives in the Green
Jungle hello
[Music]
Oh no you're smarter than I thought this
time will be
[Music]
harder oh no the picture hint is gone
friends let's remember well and find the
scary Tiger's
[Music]
voice roller
this is
hard was it this one
[Music]
a I don't think that's
correct this is a monkey's
voice we need to find the answer before
the snake eats the
tiger a I'm confused this one or that
[Music]
one hey yes even a scary tiger Withers
under my
spell
no it's the sound of a blotchy
cow once I eat the tiger I'll be the
king of the
jungle the snake is squeezing the tiger
friends hurry
quickly it's this
one
roar oh that's the answer no the king of
the jungle is me I
[Music]
say can you tell me who lives in the
jungle roar roar it's a scary tiger
with a roar here and a roar there here a
ro there a ro everywhere Ro a tiger
lives in the Green
Jungle
Roar thank you so much for finding the
animal sounds with me
[Music]
friends
ow see you next time bye
[Music]
my tail is
gone did you ever see a tail my tail a
pig's tail did you ever see a tail my
curly twirly tail a zebra's tail to
flick the bugs a kangaroo's tail to sit
up oh no no no no no no no there not my
tail did you ever see a tail my tail a
pig's tail did you ever see a tail my
curly twirly tail a peacock's tail for
beauty a dog's tail to say hello oh no
no no no no no no they're not my
tail okay I'm going to look for my tail
one more time
H I'm aha did you ever see a tail my
tail a pig's tail did you ever see a
tail my curly twirly tail a hippo's tail
to spread po a VI's tail to swim well oh
no no no no no no no they're not my
tail huh
[Laughter]
welcome to the farm ping pong's farm
animals say hello to our animal
[Music]
friends welcome to the farm ping pong's
farm animals come and meet our animal
friends the best place in the
world welcome to
the welcome to the farm horses and cows
and donkeys
Bo welcome to the
farm play with us at the bo bo play with
us at the F dog and cat and
little play with us at the
[Applause]
F welcome to the farm ping pong's farm
animals everyone is having
fun
yippe welcome to the farm ping pong's
farm animals we play together every
time
yay welcome to the
fom welcome to the
farm C dark
GRE welcome to the
farm play with us at the bar Bo play
with us at the farm K and sheep and Chen
with us at the
[Music]
farm welcome to the farm pink Fong's
farm animals the night is deep it's time
to
[Music]
sleep welcome to the farm ping pong's
farm animals lay your head down on your
bed shh it's time for
bed night time at the
F night time at the F horses and cows
and donkeys and cats and dogs and sheep
and so
on boom boom night time at the
farm boom boom welcome to the farm boom
boom welcome to the farm boom boom to
the
F welcome to welcome to Welcome to the
farm
yeah let's find the jumbled farm animal
[Music]
sounds hi
friends welcome to Pink Fong's
Farm let me introduce my animal friends
what's this
[Music]
sound I am Wolf the sneakiest villain on
pink Fong's Farm I've come to make some
[Music]
trouble quack
quack
no oh no the the sneaky wolf has jumbled
up the animal
sounds can you help me find the sounds
of my farm animals
friends oh you'll help me thank you
[Music]
friends if you don't find your sound
quickly I'm going to eat you
[Music]
oink
oink our first farm animal let's find
the cow's
[Music]
sound I'm puzzled was this
right po doodle
[Music]
do oops that wasn't the right
answer this is the sound of the rooster
letting us know it's
morning let's try one more
[Music]
time this
one one more mistake and I can eat the
cow oh
[Music]
no that was the sound of a monkey who
lives in the
[Music]
jungle I like beef the best
M the wolf is getting closer let's hurry
and find the
answer
H this
one
uh-oh we got
[Music]
it ping pong had a little fun
e-i
e-- and on his farm he had some cows e-i
e- i- o with a
here here there everywhere pong had a
little farm
[Music]
E without your sound you'll end up as my
meal you can't run away way this
[Music]
time quack
quack let's find the pig's
[Music]
sound
oink this is hard is this
right woof woof
[Music]
Ah that's not it then which animal sound
is
this woof
woof oh this is the sound of a cute
puppy then is it this
[Music]
oh oops I think we got it
wrong that was the sound of a sheep with
fluffy
[Music]
fur pork is the best please get it
wrong ow
be careful Pig the wolf is smacking his
lips we need to get the answer
[Music]
correct yes this is it oink
oink uh-oh that's
[Music]
right ping pong had a little f e i e i-
o and on his F he had some pigs E e- i-
O with an O here and an oink boink there
here and oink there and oink everywhere
and oink Pink song at a little farm E I
e-
[Music]
I I'm angry pink Fong I can't believe
you got it twice already it will be
difficult this time
[Music]
oh oh no we're in trouble there are more
options to choose from we got this
friends let's find the duck's
[Music]
sound squeeze to
sleep quack quack
[Music]
let's
see is it this
[Music]
one oh that's not
correct this is the sound of a
[Music]
kitten let's find the answer quickly
before wolf eats the
duck now let's
see this
[Music]
one oh you're my next
meal Oh
[Music]
No this must be the sound of a horse who
runs very fast
[Music]
tonight's dinner is duck M should I
roast it or boil
it I'm afraid the duck will be eaten by
the wolf hurry let's be
quick is it this quack
quack that's right no my
dinner quack quack
[Music]
no ping pong had a little farm e- i- e-
i- and on his farm he had some ducks e-i
e- i- with a quack quack here and a
quack quack there here a quack there a
quack everywhere quack quack ping pong
had a little farm e e
[Music]
thank you friends for helping me find
the correct animal
sounds see you again next time
[Music]
bye hey guys did you like our video
don't forget to click subscribe
subscribe search for ping pong on
YouTube